m
dans le cadre de son projet de mandature
2015 2021 le département de la réunion
renforce son engagement en matière de
coopération régionale avec son programme
de mobilité est insertion
professionnelle des réunionnais la
collectivité procède au recrutement et à
la mise à disposition de personnes
qualifiées au profit de pays et de
structures de la francophonie en
s'appuyant sur des dispositifs comme le
contrat unique d'insertion un contrat
d'un an renouvelable une fois destiné
aux personnes qualifiées de plus de 25
ans bénéficiaires du rsa en recherche
d'emploi
je vais partir à madagascar en tant que
directeur technique de l'association
miars je vais en fait on va travailler
avec une de mes collègues qui est ici
aussi sur des en fait le développement
des communautés locales notamment dans
le domaine de l'agriculture
donc j'ai la chance d'avoir été
sélectionnés pour partir à madagascar n
arrive en tant qu'enseignante de fle
français langue étrangère au centre
national de presse malgache et à l'état
major des armées
pardon tant qu'animatrice deux clubs de
français à madagascar à tuléar plus
précisément et je vais via des activités
ludiques et culturelles essayer
d'apprendre le français
aux jeunes lycéens que je vais avoir
avec moi au départ j'étais j'étais
affecté sur le post
deux enseignants à l'assemblée nationale
et maintenant c'est sûr
l'institut des sciences politiques
enseignant de fle à l'institut de
sciences politiques que j'ai été recruté
en tant que journaliste traductrice
ces chats news agency ces chaînes donc
et puis de google en tant que
journaliste traductrice mais de traduire
des articles pour no game français de
l'anglais vers français alors je vais à
l'île maurice et je vais être assistante
de communication à la commission de
l'océan indien
j'ai par auchan tanzanie pour travailler
à l'alliance française en tant que
coordonnateur administratif et financier
j'effectuerai également une mission
parallèle un tiers du temps un quart du
temps pour créer et à développer un
partenariat avec le parc national
da rocha donc maman et ma future mission
ça va être en inde à pondichéry à
l'alliance française en tant que chargé
d'appui aux projets culturels
une véritable opportunité
professionnelle mais surtout une seconde
chance pour ces personnes sur diplômés
moi je suis bénéficiaire verrait ça donc
je cherchais un emploi depuis
j'ai enchaîné beaucoup petit bourg et la
d'avoir un emploi
vraiment très motivant dans ma manche
c'est vraiment une très grande joie
une opportunité une chance énorme si je
dirais et
une façon de pouvoir décoller
professionnels un mois avant j'avais
fait beaucoup de demandes d'emploi
une bonne centaine et
ad j'ai pas eu de réponse ou sinon pour
celle que j'ai eu de réponse et bien
c'est négatif et du coup c'était une
opel à ce que cette invitation grande
chance à tromper
pourquoi parce que jusqu'à maintenant
j'avais beaucoup voyagé en faisant un
peu des petits boulots par ci par là
pour vous découvrir l'europe et
puyvalador j'ai envie de faire quelque
chose de plus conséquent
j'espère que ça me permettra donc faire
mais bon c'est un c'est un grand pas au
niveau
ma carrière aussi et je trouve que c'est
une opportunité que les départements
nous offre qui est vraiment pas
refusable à quelques semaines du départ
l'excitation a gagné chacun d'entre eux
avec tout même pour certains quelques
appréhensions les craintes n'ont pas
plus que ça a vraiment de craintes moi
je suis vraiment j'ai hâte de partir et
je suis ouverte à toutes les surprises
bonnes ou mauvaises
j'aime la coudée une petite touche très
sereine et puis voilà
en général je m'adapte à cette rave et
très facilement partout où je vais donc
n'ont aucune crainte
un empressement par contre oui un peu
parce que j'aime pas trop comment ça va
se passer j'ai jamais vécue aux ailleurs
qu'à la réunion en zone océan indien
donc ça veut tout dire mais sinon je
suis impatient de partir